negotiations between top congressional
democrats and the white house on a covid
19
economic recovery package collapsed
friday
neither side is giving an inch among the
sticking points
republicans insist that in order to
fully reopen
businesses need to be protected from
lawsuits if employees or customers
are exposed to the coronavirus workers
say the proposal will make it harder to
hold companies accountable on safety
companies like the one at the center of
our investigation here's cbs's nancy
cordes
45 year old mike jackson was working a
mandatory overtime shift at this
milwaukee engine plant in may
when a co-worker saw him slumped over no
one told
us that he had passed out on the job but
he was back at work two days later
verl newsom is mike jackson's mother why
do you think he went to work even if he
wasn't
feeling well they would fire you he got
four
young kids he have to take care of so he
go to work sick
jackson collapsed again and was sent to
the hospital
where he tested positive for coronavirus
he died
10 days later what hurt so bad
i went there with him when he passed
he died by himself six current workers
tell cbs news the company
briggs and stratton required them to
work face to face on the assembly line
and that managers rarely wore masks
after mike tested positive
one after another people started getting
positive test results back
forklift operator chance zombor worked
alongside mike jackson
he said the company started requiring
masks this week
more than two months after jackson's
death because the state
mandated it the company doesn't care
whether we live or die
they did everything they could to keep
people working even though they knew
about the risks briggs and stratton
declined an interview
but in a statement the company told cbs
news we do not force anyone to come to
work if they aren't feeling well
nor do we penalize them the company said
it follows cdc guidelines and that
workers can apply for
paid leave to self-quarantine the
company also provided this photo
showing plastic barriers between workers
but
another photo provided by an employee a
day later
appears to show the same barriers rolled
up and there's still people getting sick
we had a person test positive the other
day
[Music]
what do we do fighting back
might soon become more difficult if
there's
any red line it's on litigation senate
republicans have a new bill that would
shield companies from
some coronavirus lawsuits workers have
already filed suits against
walmart amazon mcdonald's and tyson
foods
what do you say to workers who worry
that your liability protections
basically give their employers license
to avoid taking the kinds of precautions
that would keep them
safe this is mainly to protect them
because the employers would only
be liable if they were grossly negligent
a month before his death
mike jackson and his co-workers
protested the lack of safety equipment
at the plant
federal safety regulators are now
investigating the worker's complaints
they should take responsibility if they
were to protect
their workers i think my son probably
still had been here
for cbs this morning saturday i'm nancy
cordes on capitol hill